voilà c'est tout simple champignelles
oui je vais faire tirer tout d'abord
maurice la carte temps oui je fais tirer
à françoise allez allez voilà tu ne
regardes pas merci voilà la regarder
mais c'est pas grave elle ne joue pas
elle annonce alors j'ai bon chrono m jl
sifflé à la mi temps je suis flou mais
voilà nous sommes prêts maurice c'est
parti
sans enfant alors monsieur ait de boeuf
de boeuf un clin d'oeil club 210
chambres et perdrix trois coups d'oeil
pour 4,4 au pied bon oeil
bonbons 5 550
alors monsieur avec deux lynx 26 vague
de baisse déjà dit à l oeil pour oeil
pour oeil 7 762 judas 8,8 dans le fer et
le beurre noir les manoeuvres d'un jeune
day in day with you et d'accolades
veille discrètement 180 oui clin d'oeil
dès jeudi déjà des centaines de lieux
fermés
curieux aussi les yeux fermés c'est une
expression courante
nous serons un jour je vois trop bien je
la prends quand même c'est bon t'as vu
l'ex déjà vie déjà dit madame 250 et de
biche
bush oui 12 2 205 alors lancé on va
rester maintenant et 250 très bien dans
les dr cheikh est à 200 c était pour
gagner plus de 250 mais on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin vous définissiez
d'assèchement le groupe iliad animé
d'aménager des talons un soir ça ne
lâche pas monsieur gobeil
si vous vous demandez tout l'ambiance
est reçue qui peut rester les blâmes à
alhama pour l'instant les yeux dans les
yeux
excellent 14 ainsi vous monsieur pour
l'instant garder là malgré ripoux règne
déjà dit déjà dit monsieur il pioche et
aux chutes excellent excellent mais
c'est de cet instant mon oeil très bonne
figure attention à rien de trop de mal à
un pied bon oeil
dès jeudi déjà des plans deuil le blonde
aux yeux bleus l'oeil d'un court 16 16
jeunes talents qui jonchaient le 10 m et
1,17 à la bnda monsieur de permis déjà
c'est déjà 10 255 des samoussas mal vu
des audi déjà dit et d'amour non car il
ya de ça que de chausser dit madame 29 8
heures ses valeurs ses valeurs vite vite
vite monsieur sur le rendement du bund à
paraître demain 19 pts et bien c'est la
pensée antique